yeah welcome to this video a fifteen
minute game against down rather strong
opponent to 271 in 15 minutes really hi
I'm down a couple of seconds which is a
bit unlucky but I needed to get a drink
I mean not it sounds like a colleague
stuff no our Bishop c5 was a bit early
maybe I should have reconsidered this
wait for in this position hmm
f4 is really a bit unusual if they want
to play a Friday usually yes start with
Knight c3 in this position so um I have
a move like g5 or I'll take that d5
that's draggy five
yeah just take on therefore no is there
something something else yeah there are
some weird ideas in this kind of
position sometimes like Bishop takes g1
Bishop g4 and then only Queen d2 is
happy it smooth I could I could I could
castle if he takes some maybe Nyjah form
with this ridiculous maybe it is night
f2 coming but he's got default and most
others so I grab it and this is them the
easiest solution so just just take on d5
now on some other moves on Knight takes
d5 there may be our replies like ever
get those Queen moves Queen to h5 for
example and I cannot really believe that
I can he can keep the poem so let's
castle first he tries to keep the spawn
Knight c3 FFF Quattro piayed and so on
c6 he cannot castle the the Bishop on c5
is is strong and if he tries he has I'll
give this check what
okay yeah maybe this was necessary I
don't know
it looks like complete madness
so 94 instantly try to make use of this
what just a simple move like c6 come on
let's play c6 it's 15-minute but I don't
want to invest so much time c6 just is
huge I mean I have got big compensation
I hope them eating sounds don't distract
too much I need the noodles like snake
here bishop the bishop on f4 the Queen
on g3 I'm in them surplus move from
would-be Knight h5 now is there some
trick sorry I don't get anything here
that edge why if you move the Queen
where and then I what I can take just
okay just can check I can take a F
Queen takes and then yeah okay this is
too much material I could play something
like nightbeat's rechecking not a
traffic we move state takes so night b3
check tags but should be three winning
the Queen but it's probably probably
giving up too many too many pieces
Knight to Knight to f5 is also also a
possibility
neither five where does he go even our
Bishop III as a possibility coming
there's also be five I mean it's like
you've got so many good moves you don't
know what to what move to play b5 is
also also strong
come on b5
because Bishop h6 there's night at five
winning bishop c7 I just moved the Queen
that's not much point in this Queen d7
for example and I cannot believe he's
able to take on p5 let's say Knight B
595 Bishop b5 the screen a5 winning of
the piece and Bishop takes b5 I mean I
cannot believe it
it's just just too much but maybe there
was not h5 for Knight f5 firm already
winning that's it's it's a possibility
what I was thinking is what is he moving
now I mean Bishop b3 besides simply
taking yeah I can just take it actually
this is this is strong Knight e4 is the
problem at the end exactly
so now if I take here and play B form
keep it simple and after Knight moves I
play Knight if I win the Queen and
that's it
not sure maybe it was one of his first
15-minute games oh no it's very high
rated they are probably just an off day
I don't know this opening went wrong
awfully maybe even even this f4 move was
the problem this is really early I'm
this this is a move that it's often
played preparing her for then I played
c6 which are also analyzed in my 45
repertoire series for black the idea
being to answer f4 with g5 and and in
this position where he went
f4 instantly there's the direct move d5
and this looks looks strong already I
mean always this is this problem here
and the difference between the two the
two the close term Kings gambit the
declined Kings gambit and let me put it
on the board there's this this opening
just the the general lines there white
controls the d5 square so there's no d5
and this being a problem isn't so such a
big deal what can often get rid of this
Bishop and he's got a good bishop
himself and most importantly black
cannot play this and in the game I
immediately am able to play this move so
on this must be must be very good we are
now not g-force maybe even a tougher
tougher means but okay I wanted to keep
it simple I was down on time already but
this is already this is of course very
very hard
this move going going for for a walk I
was expecting this and this this is good
yeah but it's not the end of the world
I was intended seasick cm opening up the
position more I mean this is this this
kind of position must be quite quite
interesting at least for luck should be
good compensation for the pawn and after
this yeah there's a multitude of good
news and this is just Queen b6 is the
computer move +5 okay what this isn't
bad at all it's always +4 something yeah
and once the Queen yeah y term had an
off David it happens to all of us yeah
thanks for watching this rather quick
15-minute game it felt more like a bits
game but it was a 15 minute yeah thanks
for watching